hi there Steve Kaufman here today I want
to talk about content for beginners and
in particular the Tennessee in in most
textbooks and in most classroom
situations to begin by teaching how to
how to sort of speak and get through
certain situations so normally we begin
with introductions hello my name is
so-and-so what is your name or and then
we move to such things as what to say in
a hotel lobby or at the train station or
at the airport or going through customs
and so forth I guess the assumption is
that many people learn languages because
they want to travel and there's nothing
wrong with this content nothing wrong at
all any content is good when you're
starting but I guess my what I question
is is the assumption that that the
learner will actually learn how to use
those I think the benefit of that
content or any content is that the
learner will start to get used to the
language but the learner in my
experience and it's certainly not it's
certainly the case with me I don't learn
them how to introduce myself and then
I'm not able to be sure that every time
I meet someone I'll be able to introduce
myself in the new language chances are I
will forget it i will get it wrong I'll
know it for a while and then I'll forget
it and that's even more so the case with
situations like the bank the train
station or any other sort of situation I
don't think it's possible to prepare
yourself for what's going to happen in
any of those situations I think the goal
has to be to improve your overall
language level so that we are not so
much learning how to say things as we
are getting used to the language and
we're getting used to the language
through content and the best content for
getting used to language is content
that's of interest so so that the you
know maybe I'm splitting hairs here but
but the objective
has to be to teach to provide
interesting content so that the learners
brain will start to form some rules and
slowly accumulate some vocabulary which
they'll learn and forget and learn and
forget and eventually start to be able
to use but the idea that you can have a
set sort of scenario set conversations
and dialogues okay now I've learned how
to introduce myself and I know that
forever and ever and now I have learned
how to deposit money at the bank and I
have learned that for a never ever now
maybe I'm assuming things maybe that's
not the assumption on the part of the
text book nor on the part of the learner
but but I've seen that that many
learners go at it with that objective
that they're can learn how to deal with
the third certain situation and I don't
believe you can do that and even if you
go if you're in a restaurant and you
haven't learned how to order you know
steak that's not the end of the world
you'll manage like this there's no great
downside risk you don't need a big
safety net you'll point at something
you'll you might remember one or two
words if it's really important to you
you look them up before you go you'll
forget when you get to the restaurant
but you'll have your little book hand
and you look it up again so I guess the
whole idea is that that the focus on
beginning content should not be so much
on trying to be utilitarian trying to
teach people how to deal with certain
situations I know the you know the the
whole industry that teaches immigrants
English in North America they feel are
going to be very utilitarian they're
going to teach them what to say at a
store they're going to teach them how to
deal with certain situations just the
basics just that you know what they need
for their everyday lives if someone's in
a working situation will only teach them
language the language that they need to
work I just don't believe that i think
that the goal at all times has to be to
raise the level of the language and and
and have somehow induce the learner to
spend as much time with the language as
possible in order to get used to the
language in order to
are as many words as possible on the
assumption that the more words that are
the learner is exposed to the greater
likelihood that some will stick and
there's no predicting which ones will
stick it may be very important words
that don't stick and unimportant ones
that state and so you know the kind of
content that I think is really good is
what some of our members are starting to
do at link where we have some of our
tutor members in who are also learners
in Japan or in Brazil the talking a
little bit about their lives a simple
diary you know a simple daily you know
here's what I did today twittering type
comments in the language and if the
learners then get interested in
following that the activities of that
person in the language if they are then
motivated to learn about the person
about their lives then they will start
to absorb the language and the advantage
there is whereas I think you know as
soon as we you know after the say three
or four months then the content should
be more natural conversation but in the
first few months inevitably it has to be
written and recorded but the more
interesting we can make it the better
and we don't have to follow the sort of
introductions followed by the train
station followed by this other stuff
these sort of can scenarios on the
assumption that's going to help the
person how to buy groceries at the store
it won't when the immigrant who's
learned how to buy a banana goes to
store the clerk will say something very
quickly inning in english and the
immigrant will be lost whereas if we say
don't worry about that you can point for
now when you're buying bananas somehow
you'll get through that situation but in
the meantime let's raise the overall
level of your English and let's not have
these minimalist expectations or
utilitarian approaches to learning
language so I mean that's just a you
know it's part of my whole sense that
that a lot of of what is is done
traditionally maybe I'm just a renegade
or something if I see
you know I get occasionally emails from
teasel teachers of English to speakers
of other languages that's the name of
their organization teachers of English
to speakers of other languages that's a
special organization and they have
seminars and they have books and they
talk about things that most of them have
probably heard many many times before
they kind of reinforce all of their I
wouldn't say prejudices but all of their
established views they're probably
closely connected with the Center for
Applied linguistics and they're all out
lobbying for more money and the amount
of money that is spent on these
organizations it's a lot of fun it's
great you know in the end what comes out
of that a lot of redundant textbooks
redundant you know exercises and stuff
when really all we need is the language
if we can get people producing content
talking in simple terms about their
lives for example getting it up
somewhere in audio and text for people
to listen to and in some systems such as
we have a link to allow people to
navigate it although ours can improve
we're working on improving it so that
people can find content a of interest
and be at their level and some means for
them to go through and you know pick out
the words they don't know and learn them
and that's all and then when they're
ready to speak have some people
available that they can speak to I don't
think it's more difficult I don't think
it's much more difficult than that I
really think that you can take all
language learning and reduce it down
essentially to what I have said in other
words gradually sort of a range of
content starting from very short bits 30
seconds one minute hello today I got up
I had breakfast with my husband and
children and we went to school that's
what I did today one listen to it 1015
times and gradually going from that
eventually hitting conversations in
conversations the vocabulary used is not
very difficult so that's good for a sort
of an intermediate learner they're
picking up on the intonation the rhythm
of the language and then you move to
more
more difficult content eventually into
specialized content professional content
literature you know whatever and along
the way when you're ready you can talk
to someone and if you make some mistakes
they'll explain it to you but you won't
be required to remember the explanation
because you're going to forget it anyway
and then they'll explain it again and
again and eventually you'll get used to
language I think it all boils down to
that I'm as usual perhaps a little bit
extreme I look forward to hearing
people's views thank you